ghost nappa team three star dodge Super
Saiyan little greed said subpoena and
provost raided year-long hiatus is past
seem like dreams and these are just a
few of my favorite things let me tell
you Oh team four star you brilliant
bastards where do I even begin with you
well a lot of you might not remember
this but way back in 2006 when martin
billany a KA little kuriboh pioneered
the abridged series format with wait
2006 one second twelve years ago is a
tenth grade
I'm hideously old anyway with the start
of yugioh the abridged series spans
casual and hardcore like unanimously
praised the content as pretty damn good
and thus a new genre villain at video
was born using their awesome nerd light
powers Kaiser pakka and Lani
have dedicated their lives to weld nut
as of yet but they will anyway if you
were online in the mid to late 2000s
you'd probably remember that everyone
and their body pillows were trying their
hand at this new format I'm telling ya
it was a bridge series out the ass but
today we're taking a look at the best of
the best a certain abridged series you
may have heard of now before I go any
further let me just hit you with a quick
disclaimer for you to ignore while
ripping me apart in the comment section
for not including your favorite episode
like with all my top ten list this is
based entirely on objective facts and
are all calculated attacks on your own
personal tastes values and family
disagreement on any front only serves to
make me more powerful and if you do
disagree [ __ ] you fight me I'm totally
not mark and these are the top 10
episodes of Dragon Ball Z abridged oh
and before you try and guess the number
one spots not going to be episode 60
honestly how predictable do you think I
am
I'm offended Khurshid oh and it's also
worth noting that this list will not be
including movies specials or musicals
guess so it's only episodes 1 through 60
I'll be taking into consideration and
once again let me be absolutely clear
that episode 60 is not taking the top
spot okay
okay cool let's get down to business to
control the world number 10 as I said
earlier when Dragon Ball Z abridged
first started it did so among a sea of
other fans trying to capture that
lightning in a bottle that little
kuriboh had let loose and while it was
definitely one of the better renditions
DBZ a still suffer from poorly written
non sequiturs with a general lack of
experience in Polish but then again it
was 2008 and so did everything else on
the internet however it was the
insufferably quotable NAPA who set the
show apart from his competition it was
less of a Dragonball Z parody and more
the wacky nappa variety show for a while
at least anyway and so in the episode
prior when the time came for nappa to be
retired
many fans myself included suspected the
show was doomed to fizzle out into
obscurity enter stage right episode 10
oh man we could not have been more wrong
the show came back in full force with
this epic three-part finale to season 1
whereas previously his role was
primarily to play the straight man to
nap his funny man but GM more than picks
up his slack left behind tragically by
his murdered partner episode 10 in my
view was truly the make-or-break episode
for the entire series and looking at the
following 9 years of DBZ eh yeah I'm
gonna chalk that one down to a make
moment it's episode 10 success and
cementing Dragonball Z a bridge as a
force to be reckoned with that earns its
number 10 spot number 9 the siege of
leningrad 1941 to 1944 a hundred days
offense 1918 operation Barbosa 1941
these are some of the most egregious
stains mankind is left in the fabric of
history senseless violence in the name
of power and greed all but a glimpse
into the cruel nature of this our human
condition and yet all pale in comparison
to the carnage the cruelty the bloodlust
that is not
I love wrestling I love Dragon Ball Z so
what's not to love about episode 20 it's
a silly action-packed run framed as a
bombastic parody of Wrestlemania
complete with a snappy commentary of
Jason Berger to tie it all together the
whole thing is just peek can you force
and it's one of the episodes I find
myself going back to time and time again
also DBZ A's renditions of Roku maybe
the greatest character in all of fiction
to throwing that out there
weird kuma grease number eight okay this
episode is a perfect example of how
creative the team forced our guys really
are and I think a lot of us ruled our
eyes when we saw the thumbnail for this
one originally suggesting that we'd have
to sit through the guy like jr. AK only
for them to not just flip the script
both throw it out entirely and write a
whole damn new one the gallic jr. sagas
plot can be summed up in a few lines but
somehow the guys at OE managed to
stretch that to us snappy eleven
episodes even thinking about it gives me
cold sweats I expected the abridged
version to be at least two episodes but
instead we thankfully got this super
weird original story about Crillon
insurance fraud and his relationship
with the gold-digging undercover cop not
Booma it's just no strings attached good
quality sitcom writing and it caught
everyone off guard it's sort of like if
Seinfeld had an abridged series holy
[ __ ] someone make Seinfeld the abridged
series I think that's the best worst
idea I've ever had oh and before I
forget quick shout-out to mr. Popo for
dealing with the garlic jr. baggage in
the swiftest way imaginable
Oh mr. Popo you're incorrigible
number seven ladies and gentlemen
introducing the one the only perfect
self mr. perfect said right mr. perfect
so this episode does a great job of
demonstrating just how powerful our
handsome villain is not only do we get
to see a final flash from Vegeta that
rivals even that of the original but
Crillon all
gets a chance demonstrate his own
finishing attack speaking of Pokemon I
wonder if Vegeta has a favorite game hey
Vegeta what's your favorite Pokemon game
crystal all right dude Jesus with an
over-the-top arrogance that puts even
Vegeta to shame mr. perfect sound proves
here that the only thing more deadly
than his raw power would be his
razor-sharp jawline I mean wit his
razor-sharp
why would I say Jolie number 6 what was
Crillon busy tension on has had a
difficult relationship to say the least
with the story of Dragon Ball it's been
up down and down time and time again for
the former crane school alumni so with
semi-perfect cell having just eaten his
brother and is about to work through a
mean case of middle form syndrome by
eating his sister tensions nick of time
arrival is a fan favorite moment both in
Dragon Ball Z and the abridged series
with high stakes and a low chance of
success cell mocks our three eyed
shoulder enthusiast for even showing his
face and that's when Tian
utters those words I say to myself every
time I read the comments section in any
of my power level series videos yeah
well you know what power levels this is
a perfect example of team four-star
understanding when to let the jokes take
a backseat and play it straight the
episode is hilarious don't get me wrong
but this scene in a comedy abridged
series nonetheless always gives me
goosebumps and that's reason enough for
it to take the number 6 spot and if you
disagree as tension hun would say he
come yourself since we're at the halfway
point I feel like now is a suitable time
to remind you that episode 60 is not
going to be the number one okay in fact
it won't feature anywhere on this list
especially not the first place okay cool
just making sure we're on the same page
here number 5 did you just talk out your
ass well to be fair Vegeta you are part
of my DNA oh that is the closest thing
you've done to damage since I've gotten
here this episode is comedy gold largely
in parrot
overzealous principal sayings just
brutalizing cell with his signature
arrogant attitude oh and his fists he
also uses his fists see how often Dragon
Balls sees Vegeta playing second fiddle
to Goku it's always great to see him
take the spotlight and really save the
day you know and 2d [ __ ] it up go on
semi perfect cell gets a few good lines
in and there are some really nice
moments between Gohan and Goku inside
the hypersonic lion-tamer
that's what makes it hypersonic go on
but once again Vegeta manages to steal
the show with his general combat banter
I also want to take this opportunity to
draw attention to how [ __ ] fantastic
Nick Landis is as Vegeta and it's
especially evident in this seat but I'm
warning you if you waste it you're gonna
regret it number four remember what I
said about episode 31 and how'd the
folks at team force tire throw out the
script and wrote their own wacky zany
adventure well this is like the opposite
of that they don't scrap the original
script they build it into a [ __ ] 16
story tall mech and uses to punch you
right in the feelings now this isn't the
first time DBZ a has played a scene
straight for dramatic purposes but it is
the first time the animates is an
entirely new scene from scratch just to
add depth and context to its characters
and the episode itself is funny there's
plenty of great jokes in here we got mr.
perfect Sal here my boy little Green is
back but come on come on we all know why
this episode is special Jesus guys you
could at least tell me I'm pretty before
you [ __ ] me like that you could hear Kid
Goku in the background as he attacks the
base two before the video cuts out which
means this all takes place in the red
ribbon army arc of Dragon Ball it's
[ __ ] wild it's like they're right in
the show from scratch armed with the
knowledge only 30 years of hindsight can
bring not only is episode 56 a fantastic
example of team four start showing off
both their comedic and dramatic writing
chops but the inclusion of Android 16
expanded backstory alone really stands
to illustrate that sometimes the fans
can understand what a project needs more
than the professionals for any video
game nerds out there Dragon Ball GT is
sonic boom and DBZ a is sonic mania next
number three racking up a cool 10
million views
only half of those being mine it's clear
to see that this one is a favorite among
the fanbase - what can I say I like
Super Saiyan Vegeta get off my back
the Gaea swoops in with her vengeance to
dominate this episode as well as 19 with
big moments hilarious one-liners and a
level of hubris we haven't seen since
Nanak the Saiyan Prince is finally gone
full slim shadey and his more than eager
to show off his new form this episode
serves as a vessel for vegeta to affirm
himself as not only one of the funniest
characters on the show but as a pure
unadulterated badass 19's self-destruct
sequence is one of the best fight scenes
in the series and doctor churros
absolute the fundament is almost as
entertaining to watch as Android 19's
introduction to the concept of fear it
just goes to show what one can
accomplish with push-ups sit-ups and
plenty of juice
number two you think you're better than
me you're nothing but an overgrown
monkey and you're nothing but an
overgrown bat think teaching keeps in
there drawing this episode holds a
special place in my heart for a number
of reasons
milk rebo's interpretation of Frieza is
by far my favorite in all dubbings of
the show outside of Japan martin billany
brings a sophistication and bratty
nature to Frieza that not only works
perfectly for this more comedic take but
also works incredibly well with masago
axes Goku the quality of this shows
skyrocketed in the Namek saga an episode
30 is the clearest indication of this in
truth in terms of sheer comedy this is
the strongest episode in my view
fantastic pacing quickly dialogue
sizeable deviations from the original
version with jokes out the wazoo now
before we get to the number one spot
which again is most definitely not
episode 60 I'd like to take a few of my
favorite moments from DBZ a that didn't
make the cut you know because I'm a
youtuber and the concept of actually
committing to the number 10 in a top 10
list is a foreign and terrifying concept
to us
number one ha you idiots
it was episode 60 all along you callable
fools it was a ruse shot you yeah okay
maybe not but you all knew it had to be
episode 60 after a year-long hiatus and
announcing that this episode could
potentially be the end of Dragon Ball Z
abridges decade-long run the internet
had its eyes on team four started to see
if they could deliver on what I would
say was the most anticipated episode of
any internet show ever but the question
is can they stick the landing let's see
here it comes
[Applause]
what i mean to say is everything about
episode 60 was worth the wait and a year
at Internet time is practically an
eternity so that's really saying
something after researching the entire
series in preparation for this list I
realized that at some instants an
instance I can quite pinpoint Dragon
Ball Z abridged became more than just a
fan-made parody and so while I'm sad to
see a go words really can't express just
how much DBZ a meant to me and millions
of others around the world I wish I had
something more profound or insightful to
say but no matter how many times I've
tried to write this paragraph nothing
feels right so with nothing else to say
I have to leave you with this team four
star sincerely thank you I've been told
you nut mark thank you so much for
watching
you